we continue our breaking news coverage
it's a great story Brittany Greiner
released this morning after nearly 10
months in prison inside Russia I just
can't get over it the WNBA Superstar was
freed in prison in a prison swap early
this morning former U.S ambassador to
Russia that's John Sullivan retired from
that position in September after serving
since 2019 he was also acting Secretary
of State back in 2018 and he joins us
from Washington Ambassador Sullivan it's
so great to have you here especially
since when Brittany was arrested in
February you were Ambassador at the time
I'm wondering if you could give us some
insight into what goes on the
negotiation process and where did they
stand when you stepped out when you
retired when you stepped down from your
position well thanks thanks very much
Gil it's it's great to be with you this
morning and you're absolutely right it
is a great day it's a great day for for
Brittany for her family for the United
States for President Biden and credit to
the president for uh having the uh the
purposeful uh attitude toward this
problem and doing the deal that God got
Brittany released there's a lot of work
that goes into this the Russians are
very very difficult uh government to
negotiate with particularly on something
like this and having spoken to my my
friends and and former colleagues both
at the embassy and here in Washington at
the state department and the White House
recently including as as early as this
morning these were extremely difficult
negotiations we're dealing with a
government that isn't Bound by law or
morals our our counterparty uh it's not
a typical diplomatic negotiation and my
understanding is that the Russians
really presented uh the president
President Biden with a take it or leave
it proposition one for one it was
Brittany uh and unfortunately we've had
to leave other Americans in particular
Paul Whelan still imprisoned in a
Russian labor camp ik 17 in mordeaux via
Russia he's been detained for just about
four years
yeah Ambassador actually I was going to
bring up Paul Whalen because um you know
we heard Joe Biden say this morning that
he's still thinking about his
imprisonment and thinking about his
family so it's obviously on the
president's mind does are the chances
that Paul Whalen is released now reduced
given that Russia appears to have been
unwilling in this round of negotiations
to even put him on the table
I wouldn't draw that conclusion uh I
think that the Russians had in mind a
particular deal in this case because
Brittany Greiner is such a celebrity so
popular in the United States popular I
might add among basketball fans and
others in Russia uh Britney's case
really uh dominated the discussion and
the focus uh I think with Brittany now
released I know my colleagues at the
White House and the state department are
turning with laser focus on Paul so on
the one hand it's an extremely happy day
a joyous day that Britney's been
released but on the other hand I know if
I were still Ambassador in in Moscow I'd
be focused now on Paul's case and the
other Americans who were detained in
Russia so it's it's a happy day but a
lot more work to do particularly for
Paul
Ambassador quickly um and you mentioned
that you have talked to a senior White
House official with intimate details on
what's going on with Britney's release
what happens next
you mean for for Brittany for Brittany
Greiner what happens yes how soon can
she actually get home I believe she's on
Route in a plane as we speak uh and will
be met uh here in the United States
you'll get uh evaluated by by Dr she's
already I'm sure being evaluated by
medical personnel on the plane I'm
confident as as we've done in Prior
cases there will be Personnel on the
plane uh medical social others who will
be helping Brittany this is an enormous
change for her I'm not sure how much she
may have known nothing uh about this
transfer until they took her to the
airport and put her on a plane you can
imagine what a jarring shock that is
but a good shock just to know you
absolutely sure better than the
alternative I know Ambassador Ambassador
Sullivan thank you very much we
appreciate your insights this morning
what an amazing day for him to have seen
Brittany he was in the position when
Britain was taken and now to see it full
circle she's on her way home 24 hours as
the president United States says and she
should be back